[Musique]
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 politique chaque semaine nous
suivons la campagne des législatives
dans les yvelines aujourd'hui deux
invités dans un instant luc miserait il
se présente sous l'étiquette front de
gauche parti communiste français dans la
11e circonscription qui couvre trappe et
elancourt notamment et puis est déjà en
plateau le candidat les républicains
dans la 12e circonscription qui comprend
entre autres plaisirs poissy le député
sortant david douillet bonjour david
dont vous êtes l'un des judokas les plus
titrées de l'histoire reconverti en
politique secrétaire d'état chargé des
français de l'étranger ministre des
sports sous nicolas sarkozy et puis là
depuis 2009 député également vous
briguer un nouveau mandat est cette
année plus que jamais le résultat du
scrutin est incertain est ce que vous
faites partie des anxieux au sein des
républicains aujourd'hui
moi j'ai toujours été très humble par
rapport à la compétition et je me suis
toujours remis en question donc quelques
étés les résultats auxquels qui étaient
les compétitions précédentes celle-ci
est comme les autres c'est à dire je
fais attention
le maire de nice christian estrosi qui
déclare le 23 mai au matin chez chez nos
confrères les républicains risque des
lendemains très difficile ça veut dire
que le bilan n'a pas été fait on n'a pas
fait le petit état des lieux au
lendemain de la présidentielle tout
c'est très rapide en fait et on a à
peine le temps de souffler on a à peine
le temps de se voir de se rassembler
la séquence est très puissante quasi
violente entre une éviction dès le
premier tour
à peine le temps de faire barrage au
front national qu'à nouveau président
est élu et dieu sait si beaucoup de
républicains ont eu la même attitude que
moi c'était à faire barrage au front
national et ensuite tout de suite
gouvernement dans lequel il ya trois de
nos amis et puis des élections
législatives qui arrive tout ça
s'emballe voilà ça va vite ça va très
vite
peut-être un peu trop pour le videur
vous êtes perdus n'ont pas perdu mais
c'est compliqué quand on est une grande
famille politique de d'avoir le temps de
réagir d'avoir le temps de se concerter
d'avoir le temps de partager le temps de
discuter dont chacun est reparti sur ces
constructions fin de ceux qui ceux qui
sont candidats comme moi et puis bon
mois personnel je vous assure que je
fais par rapport à ce que je suis ce que
j'ai toujours été c'est à dire quelqu'un
de républicains avant tout qui travaille
pour l'intérêt général avant tout et qui
souhaitent la réussite de mon pays avant
tout donc par rapport à ce que président
actuel propose quand il ya une main
tendue est ce qu'il faut accepter cette
entente ne laissait pas une main tendue
en réalité ces cds propositions qu'on
défend depuis bien longtemps
bon donc s'il n'y a pas de mains tendues
ou alors la main tendue à l'est des deux
côtés et moi quand il s'agit de prendre
une main de se prendre la main pour
faire rentrer victorieux mon pays parce
que moi je fais de la politique pour mon
pays
eh bien on y va et on y va plutôt deux
fois qu'une
donc la plupart des propositions que
fera le président pour protéger le pays
pour le développer pour créer de la
richesse pour créer de l'emploi pour
assouplir tout ce qui doit être assoupli
pour que nos entreprises soient
compétitives
bien sûr comme un seul homme je voudrais
ça veut dire qu'en cas de victoire un
personnel sur la 12e circonscription des
yvelines vous pourrez vous pourriez
travailler avec la majorité mais son
secteur problème comme on a travaillé
aussi par exemple quand il s'agit de
voter les lois pour la sécurité contre
le terrorisme
lorsqu'il ya eu les attentats avec le
gouvernement de londres
il faut arrêter de penser que chaque
parlementaire appartient de manière très
sectaire un clan non chaque palme on est
intelligent et ouvert mais pour autant
au sein de votre famille politique pour
les républicains on l'a entendu françois
baroin ceux qui vont au gouvernement se
met de facto avec arnaud la famille non
mais il ya une différence entre ça et
rentrer dans un van pour moi je reste
parlementaire donc ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que je voterai tout ce qui est
bon pour mon pays mais par contre je ne
suis pas un chèque en blanc il ya
désormais proposée est rentré au
gouvernement vous auriez refusé alors
que la question se pose pas franchement
je boite est confronté à ça prend le bon
coup voilà je vous dis ça comme ça tout
frais j'ai pas mangé pas avancé pour le
manque ou et parce que j'aurais attendu
j'aurais attendu législatives au moins
pour que les choses soient plus claires
justement pour qui une main tendue quand
on parle de main tendu la main tendue si
ya pas de même de l'autre côté il faut
que les mêmes toutes les mains soit
prenable je vous disais que je ne signe
pas un chèque en blanc c'est à dire
qu'il ya des mesures à la très concrète
on peut en parler dès maintenant si vous
voulez la hausse de la csg pour moi
c'est compliqué et une quasi
irréfutablement non parce que parce que
les retraités vont être impactés les
professions libérales vont être impactés
trop fortement
voilà là la remise à niveau du diesel du
prix du diesel par rapport au prix de
l'essence non parce qu'on change des
règles en cours du jeu que ce soit
beaucoup plus souple on a fait des
campagnes pour la promotion du deuxième
aussi aujourd'hui on change tout faut
que ça soit beaucoup plus souple même
s'il faut évidemment faire attention au
climat et puis tout ce qui concerne tout
ce qui pourrait amener trop de
communautarisme est là le président est
un peu floue là dessus là aussi je
serais extrêmement vigilant il ya aussi
un programme qui est plus marquée
peut-être plus dur encore chez les
républicains malgré tout si on compare
avec le programme du président élu les
républicains par exemple qui veulent
supprimer 300 mille postes dans la
fonction publique pour la république en
marche
c'est seulement 120 mails on va plus
loin malgré zoo mais oui on va toujours
plus loin parce qu'il s'agit nous on a
pris pas ou plutôt que d'augmenter les
impôts
travers la csg on se dit que et bien on
va pas affaiblir les classes moyennes en
réalité parce que c'est le seuil de 1200
euros par exemple si le retraité au
dessus de 1200 euros
ils sont clairement impactés l'idée
c'est de réduire les dépenses publiques
donc réduire la masse salariale de
l'état
c'est ce qui coûte le plus cher à l'état
la masse salariale donc de ne pas
remplacer un fonctionnaire sur deux et
de le faire jusqu'au chiffre de 300
milles me paraît beaucoup plus
raisonnable que de faire des économies
que d'aller à nouveau recrée our
ponctionner les français en particulier
la classe moyenne ce sont eux qui font
tourner l'économie
nous sommes sur un scrutin national avec
ces élections législatives néanmoins il
ya toujours une donnée local il faut
être élu sur une circonscription est
répondre aux besoins vous avez raté pour
toutes celles et ceux qui nous regardent
ok il ya une incidence forte nationale
ça c'est le résultat
mais un parlementaire digne de ce nom et
qui travaille bien doit d'effacer mérite
vraiment il va être ancrés localement et
surtout le comprendre parce que c'est
dans la compréhension de la
problématique de son territoire qu'il
pourra défendre à l'assemblée sa
spécificité
je peux vous assurer que les 577 députés
ont chacun et chacune dans leur
circonscription des choses extrêmement
spéciale on dit enrichissent le débat
parlementaire alors dans la 12e par
exemple qu'est ce qui fait la richesse
de cette 12e circonscription et
apprivoiser claro est ce que j'appelle
la rue urbanité c'est à dire que c'est
une circonscription extrêmement riche
intellectuellement parlant parce qu'on a
on a tous les types de populations
tournent à des urbains tels cas plaisir
ou à poissy abel 6000 habitants et puis
on a beaucoup de rural on a des petits
villages comme crêpière marvin pierre
voici sans avoir s'acharne à la grange
et cetera d'avron ou là
on a de l'agriculture on à la ruralité
avec tout ce que ça comporte avec un
monde de services
on a aussi un développement économique
notoire est là dessus c'est un de mes
fers de lance depuis je suis l'élu le
développement de la fibre avec le
département avec la région qui ont pris
ces compétences aujourd'hui le
développement de la fif c'est aussi
important que les féliciter d'hyères
pour implanter des entreprises et créer
des emplois
voila j'aimerais que vous juste revenir
sur les résultats de l'élection
présidentielle j'imagine que vous les
avez regardés sur votre circonscription
parce que c'est aux mêmes annonciateur
un petit peu rappelé quelques chiffres à
plaisir françois fillon était derrière
emmanuel macron derrière jean-luc
mélenchon aussi 18 5 % pour françois
fillon
près de 30% pour emmanuel macron sur
poissy aussi emmanuel macron et et était
en tête de sept points à peu près au
delà au dessus de françois fillon quand
vous avez vu ces résultats vous vous
êtes dit ça va être très compliqué pour
les élections législatives
je me suis dit je vais prudente comme
d'habitude et surtout que ça ne reflète
pas une réalité de terrain
voilà la réalité du terrain cette
élection a été très très complexes à
analyser
parce que entre les déçus de la droite
qui n'ont à cause d'un candidat qui
s'est révélé être englué dans des
affaires et on a tous découvert ça avec
stupéfaction qui a eu du mal à se
défendre et qui a payé dès le premier
tour tout c'est toute cette histoire là
tout change donc des gens sont partis un
peu partout donc ce sont ventilés
d'autres sont restés mais je ne
m'appelle pas françois fillon voilà je
ne suis pas présenter aux
présidentielles
j'ai des valeurs oui de droite oui mais
je veux je rappelle encore une fois en
particulier venant de la société civile
moi même ma première des valeurs c'est
de servir mon pays et de protéger
l'intérêt général protéger la qualité de
vie dans cette circonscription dans
cette 12e circonscription parce qu'elle
est géniale je les adore et il ya des
gens formidables l'intérieur les
candidats sur cette 12e circonscription
la liste provisoire encore il manque
encore quelques étiquettes elle n'a pas
été validée par la préfecture qui
s'affiche il ya quatorze candidats
candidate
vous avez un adversaire une à deux
c'est dans cette circonscription plus
ciblée qu'un autre en marche
non je la connais pas papy j'ai essayé
évidemment on aime bien connaître contre
qui on se on est mis en rivalité
je sais pas qui c'est et personne ne
sait qui c'est bon voilà c'est comme ça
je fais pas de mauvais esprit mais c'est
une réalité
alors sans doute on va apprendre à
connaître au fur et à mesure de cette de
cette campagne j'ai rencontré une fois
dame très agréable mais j'ai bon
et aucune activité dans aucune
association de la circonscription qu'une
activité des quelles que soient les
merdes mais comme une des 23 communes
qui me supporte qui me porte ne la
connaissent pas non plus bon voilà c'est
un candidat de la pluie qu'on marche
mâcon je crois qu'elle a plein partout
de cette
avec ce cv là
je pense que pour servir services sdd pu
desservir on s'approvisionne pas
parlementaire du jour au lendemain il
faut déjà avoir eu une envie de servir
dans quel que soit le domaine d'ailleurs
mais une envie de vraiment s'investir
pour les citoyens que son politique wire
bon voila j'ai rencontré des gens dans
marche qui ne l'ont même pas vous dans
la campagne du président pendant sur la
circonscription wire bon voilà c'est
quelqu'un de 2,7 un scrutin oui aux
seules inconnues fille oui c'est connu
et inconnu oui vous êtes vous êtes le
chef de file les républicains dans les
yvelines j'aurais juste prendre quelques
instants pour finir cet entretien sur
cette question dans le département dix
des douze circonscriptions sont à droite
est ce que vous pensez pouvoir conserver
ou en tout cas vous vous êtes fixé des
objectifs avoués aux autres quand tu
vois je rêve d'un grand chelem
bon jeu c'est encore possible mais si
vous allez me trouver optimiste mais
j'adore ça j'adore être optimiste et et
j'ai toujours mille quand même des beaux
et gros défi et je pense qu'on a les
moyens de fer quand il est chaud sera
compliqué sera extrêmement dur mais des
deuils qui s'annonce difficile mais je
pense aussi peut-être à la 10e
circonscription et avoir votre regard
dessus parce que c'est une ancienne des
républicains qui se présente sous
l'étiquette jeu c'est rare république en
marbre aurore bergé qui se présentent
dans la 10e face à jean frédéric poisson
du parti chrétien démocrate
vous en pensez quoi de cette affiche de
voir une ancienne de votre famille
politique
moi j'aime pas je n'aime pas critiquer
qui que ce soit chacun fait ses choix et
les gens tireront les conséquences
qu'ils doivent en tirer
voilà rue berger a les qualités elle
s'est positionnée très souvent sont dans
beaucoup dax très souvent visiblement
elle n'a pas trouvé lac ce qui lui
plaisait chez l'américain don qu'elle a
été le chercher ailleurs voilà c'est
tout c'est comme ça
il faudra être vigilant sur d'autres
circonscriptions la huitième la 9e aussi
où là on a quand même on a front
national qui est assez élevé bon sur la
11e sur benoît hamon beaulieu il se
représente
oui
hum ça dans la partie claret ca va être
compliqué pour lui le prophète dans son
pays là ça va être très compliqué
quelqu'un que j'aime bien benoît hamon
mais bon je sais que mélenchon est
arrivé en tête la barre vous savez
françois la ville de trappes ça va être
loin c'est loin loin loin d'être évident
jean michel fourgous qui est investi l
encours a déjà gagné ces deux
circonscriptions il a les moyens de le
faire voilà il a toutes les qualités il
a tout le réseau et à toute l'énergie
pour ça je lui souhaite beaucoup de
réussite même si benoît hamon vous
l'avez dit connaissait plutôt bien oui
oui vous entendez plutôt bien avec lui
marei c'est pas parce que on imposer
politique on s'apprécie pas pleinement
heureusement d'ailleurs merci david
douillet c'est joli politique se
poursuit je rappelle que vous êtes
candidat pour ce nouveau mandat dans la
12e circonscription des yvelines dans un
instant c'est lui qui miserait qui se
présente sous l'étiquette notamment du
parti communiste dans la 11e
circonscription que nous allons recevoir
mais tout d'abord le point sur la
candidature de pascal thévenot c'est le
maire de vélizy il se présente dans la
seconde la 2e circonscription
présentation signé mélanie poquet et
nicolas landry pascal thévenot 50 ans et
le député sortant de la 2e
circonscription des yvelines un mandat
d'un an seulement en mars 2016
il est élu avec plus de 72% après la
démission de valérie pécresse
je tire un bilan plutôt positif et j'ai
eu aussi un peu de chance c'est que je
suis arrivé
directement au niveau de la loi sur le
travail qui était donc mon passé de chef
d'entreprise j'étais aussi investi et
dans le monde syndical patronal
donc c'est un monde que je connais
parfaitement j'ai pu totalement
m'investir dès le départ et même
christian jacob avait fait confiance
pour participer à des auditions qui
permettait de deux mètres d'alimenter la
loi de faire des amendements en 2008 il
fait partie de la majorité municipale de
vélizy-villacoublay commune dont il est
élu maire en 2014
un territoire auquel il est très attaché
j'ai fait mes études à versailles j'ai
fait ensuite des études supérieures à
saclay où j'étais aussi investi dans le
monde dans le monde associatif et je
pense que c'est une envie qu'on doit
avoir et mais les gens lors que le
ressentent ses axes de campagne la
sécurité la politique familiale le
logement l'emploi mais aussi
l'apprentissage
si on veut relancer l'apprentissage
pourquoi un apprenti très bon moins bien
lotis qu'un ingénieur
nous ce qu'on propose c'est que
l'apprentissage les écoles
d'apprentissage soit financée par l'état
et pour ça c'est à peu près un milliard
cinq dont il suffit de supprimer tous
les emplois aidés qui sont des artifices
statistiques pour mettre le paquet sur
l'apprentissage 16 autres candidats se
présentent aux élections législatives le
11 juin prochain pascal thévenot
affrontera notamment jean noël barrot
candidat de la république en marche et
yasmine belmadi représentant du front
national nous continuons ce 7,8
politique à présent dans la 11e
circonscription trappe elancourt la
verrière ou encore le mesnil saint denis
sont notamment concernés bonjour luc
miserait je vous représenter le parti
communiste français le front de gauche
dans ce scrutin force est de constater
que le l'union n'a pas été possible avec
les autres forces de gauche il y a eu
des discussions des tentatives de
discussions mais avec les insoumis et le
parti communiste les discussions donc
pas pu aboutir j'imagine que vous le
déplorez alors on le déplore mais plus
que des discussions puisque en fait nous
avons des assemblées citoyennes qui se
déroule depuis septembre dernier
le très très régulièrement à laquelle
auquel parfois des militants de france
insoumise sont venus participer ces
assemblées citoyennes ont souhaité par
rapport à l'implantation locale d'avoir
un député qui soit bien représentatif
par son implication et donc ont proposé
ma candidature
les discussions ont achoppé
parce que bien chacun sur des raisons
différentes
réclamait
le poste de titulaire et donc ya pas pu
avoir d'accord donc au final ça dessert
toutes les formations politiques ça
dessert les formations politiques mais
ça dessert surtout cesser ces
tractations qui parfois sont un peu trop
politicienne ça dessert surtout la
population parce que c'est elle qui va
souffrir de monsieur macro comme
président de la république est alors
pourquoi maintenir votre candidature
finalement parce qu'il n'y a pas toutes
les raisons quand même pour que le parti
communiste le front de gauche et les
citoyens qui ont décidé de s'engager
dans ce rassemblement soit toujours ceux
qui sont les dindons de la farce et qui
s'écrase et qu'ils se soumettent à la
france insoumise donc la france
insoumise et l'accord pour les accords
quand c'est elle qui est titulaire à un
moment donné il faut de déséquilibre
puisqu'il n'y a pas d' équilibre
possible il n'y a pas de raison non plus
de 2 de s'agenouiller en permanence vous
êtes la mort et le néant ce sont des
propos de jean luc mélenchon tenu il ya
un sms aux dirigeants du parti
communiste français a pire leurs en
l'occurrence sms qui étaient envoyés et
qui n'a pas été démentie d'ailleurs donc
ces propos ont été tenus vous êtes la
mort et le néant les propos de la france
insoumise envers le parti communiste
français
ce sont des mots difficiles des mots
durs oui relations sont loin d'être au
beau fixe
ce sont des mots empreints de mépris et
de la suffisance dont certains peuvent
faire apparaître de temps en temps il a
traité également ian brossât
maire-adjoint de paris de parasites
voilà donc ben nous on essaye de ne pas
rentrer dans ce débat là donc vous
entendrez pas de notre part d' insulte
mais plutôt le souci de nos populations
et nos populations elles peuvent pas
attendre cinq ans la prochaine échéance
parce qu'elle souffre aujourd'hui et
donc c'est important qu'il y ait des
représentants qu'ils soient porteurs de
non pas des de leurs conversations à eux
mais de la réalité de terrain
c'est par exemple
pas plus tard que hier je rencontrais
une enseignante qui était très
préoccupée par ce qu'il va se passer au
niveau de l'éducation nationale parce qu
on présente ça comme une priorité la
mesure mais derrière ça génère quoi donc
il ya de fortes inquiétudes et donc il
ya besoin de deux députés qui sont
engagés comme l'ont été les députés
communistes et front de gauche pendant
la dernière législature
les seuls à se poser réellement à ce
gouvernement de régression sociale et
et ceux qui ont été l'honneur de la
gauche on aurait pu s'appuyer là dessus
jean luc mélenchon on décide de faire un
autre choix au lieu d'un rassemblement
ouvert et évolutif et constructif il
fait le choix d'un rassemblement faire
mais bon c'est son option c'est une des
raisons aussi qui nous ont poussés à
pousser notre candidature
on va revenir sur quelques points de
programme précis et puis parler de cette
11e circonscription où vous vous
présentez également mais juste pour en
terminer avec ce sujet est ce que
aujourd'hui la france a soumise à vider
de son contenu le parti communiste est
ce qu'aujourd'hui partie communisme
existait aussi au delà de la france
insoumise mais le parti communiste le
front de gauche existent et existeront
le front de gauche jean-luc mélenchon
dit ça n'existent plus parce que lui on
est parti mais le front gauche a été
créé il était encore au parti socialiste
le front gauche continue à se réunir à
débattre à échanger et à faire en sorte
que la vie politique sorte grandie donc
nous continuerons à exister que ya une
volonté pour quelqu'un qui prône la
coopération les coopératives de dopé a
surtout ce qui est la gauche de dans un
mouvement hégémonique et on voit bien ce
que donnent les mouvements et chez
monique c'est ce que le parti socialiste
a voulu faire pendant des décennies et
on voit l'état dans lequel il est
aujourd'hui et surtout l'état dans
lequel il a mis la gauche
donc nous les valeurs de gauche on y
croit toujours les valeurs de solidarité
de coopération de fraternité et c'est ça
et c'est de cela que nos électeurs ont
besoin valeurs de gauche programme de
gauche augmentation des salaires par
exemple ça fait pas réellement position
que vous allez porter plan d'urgence
pour le logement aussi si on rapporte ce
à l'échelle de la 11e circonscription
aujourd'hui ce sont aussi les les
priorités du terrain vous constatez sur
des communes comme trappe par exemple la
verrière au 6 mai et au delà et ou de là
mais problème du logement oui il ya des
tas de demandes qui ne sont pas
satisfaites donc de cette situation très
problématique problèmes de logement
aussi de par sa configuration 1 à la
fois on
né dans des villes qui sont relativement
jeune mais en même temps il ya un
vieillissement de la population
il n'y a pas assez de logement par
exemple en rez de chaussée pour des
personnes en situation de handicap pour
des personnes qui vieillissent et qu'ils
ne peuvent plus assumer ddd
les édifices qui ont été conçus à une
époque on pensait les choses
différemment
donc problème de logement mais problèmes
de transport on a pris l'exemple de la
gare de triage par exemple de trappes
qui est en jachère aujourd'hui qui
pourrait être développé ce sont des
emplois donc c'est des emplois
en même temps c'est diminuer le nombre
de camions sur les routes donc c'est
diminuer la police la pollution
atmosphérique dont c'est diminuer les
problèmes de santé publique auquel sur
lesquels on passe de manière un peu trop
rapide on parle de santé on a les
problèmes par exemple avec la
l'ancienne clinique de trappes
autoproclamé hôpital de l'ouest parisien
privé qui appartenait à une certaine
époque a ses médecins qui aujourd'hui à
partir d'un fond de pension
donc ces gens là se font de l'argent les
dépassements d'honoraires les gens qui
ne peuvent plus se soigner ça c'est des
problèmes réels problèmes d'éducation
on en parlait tout à l'heure mais de
manière très succincte mais va falloir
quand même qu'on nous explique comment
l'année qui scolaire qui s'écoule où il
ya eu tant de d'enseignants qui n'ont
pas été remplacés par exemple parce
qu'il y en avait pas comment on va faire
en sorte d'en créer de nouveaux comme ça
d'un claquement de doigts si c'est pour
les recruter à l'anpe au pôle emploi
aujourd'hui avec pour tout bagage en
pédagogie en psychopédagogie si elle
fait ces derniers temps dans son panier
jeu mais ce qui est fait depuis des mois
et même des années
eh bien
ça c'est une situation qui est assez
catastrophique donc voilà pourquoi on a
besoin de députés qui s'engagent
réellement sur les valeurs de gauche que
j'aimerais aussi vous faire réagir sur
les questions de sécurité quelles
propositions vous porter aujourd'hui en
matière de sécurité on sait la question
de l'islamisation des questions des
départs vers la syrie concernent
notamment trappe il ya de nombreux
départs vers la syrie est aussi des
problèmes d'insécurité du du quotidien
il ya un tireur qui a été appréhendé
juste aujourd'hui où nous enregistrons
c'est cette émission est qui qui était
en cavale pendant une quinzaine de jours
après avoir fait un mort à plaisir et de
blessés à trappes quelles sont les
réponses de sécurité qu'on peut apporter
aussi sur ce territoire alors les
réponses elles sont diverses d'abord
nous on pense que justement il faut pas
moins de fonctionnaires dans ce pays
mais il en faut davantage dans
différents secteurs vous parler de celui
de la sécurité il ya besoin de plus de
policiers faut quand même rappeler que
c'est monsieur sarkozy qui a diminué le
nombre de policiers dans ce pays donc il
ya besoin de plus de policiers et a
besoin plus d'enseignants il ya besoin
de plus de personnels de santé
donc on a besoin de plus de
fonctionnaires après c'est la question
de comment on les finance
mais
donc ça c'est une première réponse on a
besoin d'une police de proximité qui a
été elle aussi écartée par monsieur
sarkozy
donc on a besoin d'une police de
proximité qui répondent plus aux besoins
et puis on a aussi besoin de moyens
supplémentaires dans la justice parce
que les les dossiers qui traînent
pendant des mois et c'est ça c'est pas
propice à aussi bien à la justice qu'à
la réinsertion des personnes
on a besoin de plus d'éducateurs
spécialisés pour travailler sur la
prévention
et là il ya un travail énorme à faire et
qui aujourd'hui a été sous l'influencé
par exemple du conseil départemental
très recentrer sur une forme unique de
réponses qui nous semble pas adapté donc
sur la sécurité
il ya énormément à faire sur la
prévention sur l'accompagnement et
surtout sur l'accompagnement aussi
quelque chose qu'on évoque rarement mais
qu'on sur lesquels nous on peut être
sensible parce que on a quand même un
établissement pénitentiaire sur le
territoire de cette circonscription sur
l'accompagnement des sortants
et donc là aussi en terme de personnel
il ya des sous-effectifs dans les
prisons françaises on le sait les
conditions sont excécrables donc il ya
besoin d'investir dans ce domaine la
tour qui lie à une ré elle réinsertion
en un mot très rapidement quelques
secondes votre avis sur les premiers
jours du gouvernement macron moi je n'en
attends rien de positif on voit bien il
ya une obsession sur la case du code du
travail comme si les problèmes d'emploi
et de travail en france se situe à ce
niveau là un problème d'investissement
mais on peut pas attendre de quelqu'un
qui vient des banques d'affaires c'est à
dire des gens qui sont dont la première
mission c'est de faire des regroupements
pour faire des licenciements c'est de
fermer des usines qui gagnent de
l'argent pour que les actionnaires
gagnent plus de gens qui sont là pauvre
préparer à accompagner l'évasion fiscale
on peut pas attendre de ces gens là que
on est des solutions pour développer
l'économie réelle et donc la
représentante apparemment dans marche
qui vient de ces banques us id barclays
hsbc
ça nous semble pas quelque chose de
d'intéressant pour nos populations
merci duc miserait candidat parti
communiste français front de gauche dans
la 11e circonscription des yvelines
prochain 7,8 politique le 31 mai
[Musique]